any you're kind of that we were to
saying your sexual awakening was was
sort of was a two-dimensional sexual
awakening oh it's true I was wanting to
be knows like what you know who would
that your first crushes and and and I
did I loved the Lion King when I was
younger and I had a wig so sweet she can
sing really well that's wrong and is it
you like Maid Marian as well yes that is
true she's a fox though what did you
that tunic is worn very low I notice
he's packin we forced you to say you had
a slight in the yen for Wilma Wilma
Flintstone yeah Bradley but you you were
top of your head you were just like oh
yeah sexy cartoons got him so who did
you like well there's two of them depend
now old you are
Shiro who'd oh look at Syrah then
chitara chitara classic
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know who you are but I have a
particular set of skills skills that
make me a nightmare for people like you
if you go now that'll be caught the
panda panda panda perfect cheese call
panama fries